good afternoon welcome to this fairly
unique and interesting opportunity here
we have where where we've got a talk
about architecture in the School of
Forestry environmental studies and this
may be a first I'm not sure but we've
had the great pleasure to have with us
today two architects who are leading the
initiative to build tall buildings with
wood as structural materials Michael
Greene who is from Mike mga Michael
Greene architects is a firm he's just
started he left his old firm when a
couple of weeks ago and it's just
started a new firm he's in Vancouver
Canada and he's put out a document
called the case for tall wood building
which I'm sure you'll hear more about
during his talk which has really got the
airwaves fluttering about what things we
can and cannot do with wood and our
other guest is Andrew wah from wah
thistleton architects from London he he
and Michael and I met in Bangalore India
at the fal conference on the joy of wood
and when I heard the kind of work they
were doing I immediately invited them to
come here to Yale so I don't think I
need to say much more in a lot of
introduction welcome we're very glad to
have you and look forward to your talk
you know what they use these guys so
we're going to we're going to tag-team
this this presentation but it's a huge
pleasure to be here we've had a really
fun day already and for me it's really
special because I spent eight years
living here in New Haven almost nine
years so it's pretty great to be back
I've been in Vancouver the last 14 so
it's pretty nice Andrew and I end up
lecturing a lot together around the
world because we're in this unique
conversation we're having and so we're
going to talk about tonight but it's
great fun because we get to come
together Andrews practice in London we
get to come together and sort of share
our current work and the issues we're
looking at and learn and grow from each
other so this is a pleasure just to be
able to get to do this together again
it's been since I guess when we were
India with Mary since we lost it so
we're going to tag I'm just going to
start and you just don't see to it we're
kind of working work I feel I should
break into Seoul I know it feels fuzzy
with it so if I do then please actually
you know you know one question just just
for because it is interesting as
architects for us to be here is anybody
in the room and architect who are we
looking at one two three four okay and
everybody else forestry or general
public or forestry hands Landscape
Architecture excellent building official
Oh excellent
how about engineers anybody engineer
yeah good okay it's a crab great
we just we flick this fool you go yeah
okay okay so what we're going to talk
about this evening is is the principle
the idea that word is a word as a viable
alternative to concrete and steel so the
work that Michael and I are doing is not
is it's not principally looking at at
timber at word as a as an aesthetic
material but timber and wood and the
idea of it being an alternative or the
principle it can be and should be seen
as an alternative to concrete and steel
so why would
this is where we start from this is
where the essential kind of the crux of
the problem comes from seven billion
people which is the big news at
Christmas so when we were born and
weirdly within a couple of weeks each
other and they have to guess who's the
oldest but we can leave that too this is
the there are three and a half billion
people on the planet so this is a this
is a this is our problem this is our
generations problem this is for us to
deal with us three billion people need a
home by 2035 a hundred thousand homes a
day so this is this is for our
profession for our industries this is
the this is the problem of our lifetime
of these seventy percent will be urban
by 2050 if we have an understanding of
the fact that to house all these people
in order to be able to live in societies
which can function adequately we need to
densify our cities so we're looking at
an understanding dense urban contexts in
order to be able to to house these
populations and how we do this because
the building industry itself as we stand
is responsible for 40% of the
consumption of world's resources and
here what I've done actually rather than
saying 25 self which is giving you a
range because I don't know you know when
any of us research these things you can
go to the concrete lobbying organization
and they will say one figure and you go
to Greenpeace and you get it right on
the other end of the spectrum and people
are quoting these all over the place so
what we've done here is to is to use
some figures with within ranges of these
kind of quotes so for this one here 25
to 40 percent of the consumption of
energy on the planet is from the
construction industry from the building
industry itself 30 to 40 percent of the
emission of greenhouse gases is from
construction and 30 to 40 percent of
solid waste generation now as we stand
the building industry itself principally
uses concrete and steel for these
buildings concrete itself is responsible
for between five and eight percent of
global greenhouse gas emissions so that
makes it the fourth single biggest
emitter of greenhouse gases
steal for 4% sober per volume in terms
of in terms of the construction industry
the biggest emitter of greenhouse gases
now this is compared importantly to
airline travel 1.6% shipping 3% and
again concrete 5% so if you build in
timber you can fly what you like I use
my cue so now we're going to switch over
and I guess you know this really is the
essence of how both of us came to this
discussion I come from BC where it's
obviously a big timber industry so it's
an important discussion in my community
but my interest is an architect and
andrew's interest certainly is around
the issue of climate change around the
issue of environmental footprint of the
buildings we build and looking for a new
responsible way so much like Andrew
suggested is that the fact that the
world is urbanizing at this
extraordinary rate means that we need to
not look at solutions that are rural or
suburban scale which much of the
architecture industry has been looking
at for a long time of greener solutions
we really need to look at the big
buildings we make and again the bones of
those big buildings is really where we
found we need to start from square one
so effectively in all those statistics
and and and to go one step further on
the stats that that Andrew just talked
about here in the United States
it's almost 50 percent of greenhouse gas
emissions are related to the building
industry and almost 50 percent of energy
is related to the making and manufacture
and operating and buildings so those
numbers are actually slightly skewed
down worldwide as they are here in North
America they even more extraordinary so
obviously to us the reality is the big
problems equals big opportunities equals
big solutions and that's really why
we've sort of stepped into the fray of
very very large kind of systemic change
discussions about how we build in urban
buildings largely all of us are thinking
greener today and I I always love to use
this quote I put my money on solar
energy I hope we don't have to wait for
oil and coal to run out before we tackle
it and the great thing about that quote
is Thomas Edison said it to Harvey
Firestone and Henry Ford and he said at
80 years ago and the thing I like to
point out
is that of course is we are all working
hard to now build greener buildings and
add photo for text to our buildings and
other green building systems the reality
and what we do ultimately is that the
only building material that we really
build with large quantities anyway that
is fundamentally grown by the Sun is of
course wood which becomes a very easy
moniker for why we want to do this
but ultimately isn't the issue that when
we put all this energy all of this
process into the basic building
materials of steel and concrete really
ultimately we're trying to compete with
photosynthesis and we don't have a
prayer keeping up with it so
fundamentally we need to look to
solutions that take that advantage and
what's some of you certainly the
forestry industry know this the forestry
school know this statistic but that
fundamentally unlike concrete that 5 to
8% emitter of greenhouse gas and steel
wood on the other hand has a great
capacity to not only use less energy to
be turned into from a tree into lumber
but also has the ability to sequester
carbon at the rate of roughly one cubic
meters who is storing one tonne of
carbon dioxide so not only are we not
putting it into the system with our
structural system we're looking at how
we can ultimately store it and change
the whole dynamics of buildings
so obviously wood is a renewable
resource and that ability to sequester
carbon are the two critical components
that really begins our conversation
tonight
the other big starting point is really
to say that when you look at a map like
this a conf iou's net change in forest
area and when you look at it what we
have to recognize is these ideas as
important as they are they also can be
detrimental if they're not managed in an
appropriate way so if we don't source
the wood we're going to talk about in
sustainably from sustainably managed
forests we're really doing a great
disservice and what we'll see likely is
that in different parts of the world
these issues will be more challenged
than others to do that here in North
America in Europe we have the chance to
source from from reasonably well-managed
forests we're very well managed at times
but obviously the southern hemisphere
where you see all that red is of great
concern that we don't exasperate the
issues of deforestation
and so every time we talk about it we
underscore that this is an important
beginning so kind of stepping back and
why is it that we're here today and
looking out at the cities that we all
are used to living around why are they
built the way they are and obviously the
answer that's really the Industrial
Revolution the sort of onset of wrought
iron and and ductile steel the
introduction of concrete and being able
to move it on mass and the Industrial
Revolution allowed us to reshape the
skylines of every city on earth and now
at this point every city on earth
largely is starting to look the same we
build the same way everywhere with those
two materials and the big change is what
we just talked about the only reason to
start over and reinventing the wheel
essentially on tall buildings is
ultimately the issue of climate change
and that's why this is a new
conversation that we're trying to have
it's really only the last 10 years as we
all start to get our heads into it that
this even becomes an appropriate
conversation steel and concrete are
great materials until you consider their
footprint and the other reality is
what's happened over the last 100 years
is although a hundred years ago we were
able to build very significant large
wood buildings and historically even
dating back a lot longer we built large
wood buildings what's happened over the
last hundred years is our building codes
have slowly actually taken away and
actually capped the limits of what we
were allowed to build so in this diagram
here this is a four story wood building
based on the maximum we were allowed to
build in British Columbia again a very
progressive wood culture but that was as
tall as we were allowed to build in wood
and a couple years ago they changed that
to allow six storeys in 2009 which was I
think the first in north america to
allow us to go to six storeys and what
they were imagining is taking two by
four kind of construction going bigger
but by the time we passed that six
storey change my good friend andrew here
had already built his update right 2008
but it had already built a building that
we're going to he'll talk about in a
minute this nine stories tall in London
so our building code in Canada which was
the most progressive in North America at
that time was still not even catching up
with what Andrew had already done which
is very for us
when you want to create these ideas but
more importantly the way I always tell
the story as I was riding my bike with
my son across Japan and I had got a text
message from the office saying hey it's
really great six story just code just
passed in BC isn't that exciting and I
quickly emailed or texted my office back
and said that's great guys but I just
came out of a building this tall and
more importantly it was built 1,400
years ago in a higher earthquake zone in
a wet climate like BC where I live and
yet if we could do it 1,400 years ago
why can't we do it today and the fact is
no place on earth largely no place on
earth has a code that actually
understands and accepts the idea that we
would ever consider building that big
today with some slight exceptions in
places like the UK and and you know
frankly there are many places like
Russia as a cap on three stories some
places Switzerland not long ago had two
stories as maximum so I guess what that
comes to is the idea that we are at a
moment in time a real transfer
transformation in time in the way we
build and that in some ways it reflects
the era of Gustave Eiffel and that when
he stepped out for the World's Fair and
said he was going to build this building
in wrought-iron at the time city
councillors didn't like it many city
councillors in the city of Paris said
okay we'll let you build it but you have
to tear it down five years from now
because it's such an ugly eyesore and of
course today it's the symbol of France
and it changed the way many people
imagine what was possible what in turn
happened of course is what we all know
is the great race that happened from
city to city around the world to build
high so the Chrysler Building was going
up in New York and then the Empire State
Building had to be taught taller and
what that was doing was pushing our
engineers pushing our thinking and our
imagination to the ceiling so that we
basically shaped the cities now that
we're all used to such that we never
walk by a 60-story tall building and
sort of think it's going to fall down on
us we became accepted and accustomed to
it and yet strangely enough with with
wood where you get into it in more
detail the opposites happen we've become
over the last 100 years our ideas that
you can't possibly hold up a big bill
would my office that I just moved into
just a week and a half ago is 105 year
old building heavy timber and eight
stories tall eight stories measured from
the parking garage with big giant solid
Timbers obviously we were doing 100
years ago in many places not just my
office and and yet we've lost that sort
of sense of opportunity so the great
thing is the race is on so right there
is nine the nine story one is Andrews
building Murray Grove but there's
proposals in Norway there's proposal and
Austria their proposals happening all
over the world now for us to start
creating the race and build real
buildings of these Heights I can't
remember where we transition we're going
to find out in a second
so really basically I mean we are going
to tradition transition here the change
starts with the materials so we're going
to talk to you about mass timber which
is the material that we're both working
in which is massive engineered Timbers
so these are large like we're here today
looking at the glulams above us here LS
ELLs which is a laminated laminated
strand lumber laminated veneer lumber
lvl glue lambs and CLT CLT is the
material which my office has been
working with principally C L T's are
very simple very straightforward
material its secondary grade timber
planks about an inch thick by three
inches wide and they're laid out and
glued using a water-based PVA adhesive
and then cross laminated against each
other so putting it laid out at 90
degree angles so it's like a jumbo
plywood is what we're talking about and
then those panels come out of the
factory about 50 feet by about 12 feet
wide and then as CNC cut to the
appropriate shapes for for their use so
talk to you about a case study and this
is a this is my office this is us this
is the cafe and in East London opposite
my office this is me here and this is me
here and this is me here and this is me
over here so we're a little office that
tries to look a lot bigger than we are
so Murray Grove is about 15 minutes walk
from my office here this is the Jolly
Roger pub on Murray Grove which was
closed down by the council and because
they plan one too many bank robberies in
there and and we got the the Commission
to look at doing an apartment building
there from a local developer from an
East End developer and we had a long
conversation with them about the
opportunity of building this building in
timber which was a which was an amusing
conversation in hindsight they were we
built a building from cross laminated
timber about five years previous to that
and every time a client came in the door
we discussed with them the idea or the
principle of doing these buildings in
cross laminated timber in massive timber
and after years of refusal and years of
people just getting up and walking out
of my office we managed to hone this
argument down in terms of of the
argument to be presented so we have this
very clear understanding of the client
of the nature of the advantages of
building in heavy timber so we sit the
client down talk to them about this
building here we have a I'm going to
shine this in my eye trying to find out
which waiters they get honeycomb cross
laminated timber structure so every
panel it's working in this building so
this is a building which we're talking
about completely in timber so the
elevator shaft the stair shaft the
external walls floor slabs a lot of the
internal walls all made from massive
timber so the whole thing acts as a
honeycomb if you like which means that
you don't have the same necessity for
columns or load paths traveling in
direct lines through the building which
means you can alternate the plan across
the floors so this is a decided
advantage for our client so cross
laminated timber has the advantages of
like a jumbo plywood if you like has the
advantages of acting as a beam as when a
wall will act as a beam so the walls are
carrying the load from across across the
length of the wall and the floor slab
will work in both directions so you have
a you have the the primary Timbers on
top and below and that's your primary
low path and then the Timbers in the
middle will give you a secondary low
path
which makes your slab stiff across the
width um in terms of moisture
instability again they're very stable
materials so we had we had a terrible
thing happen about last summer the end
of last summer reached the dizzy heights
of about 75 degrees in London and we had
one of the one of the cladding panels
popped off the building and fell onto
the sidewalk
once they narrowly missing a baby but
it's not the case but we so everybody
you know so of course the developer
phones me up on the weekend and you know
running down there and everybody's like
well this is just because of the timber
system you know because of your timber
structure so we had to resurvey the
building after two years of complete two
and a half years complete and on
reserving the building we found that the
whole building had moved over the period
since construction by four millimeters
which is in metric I know it at eight of
an inch so in boggle as we say England
so I'm the sketch that we do we show our
clients that we discuss with it with the
clients that come in is to talk about
this building instead of a slab and
Colin buildings such as you're building
concrete to talk about a panelized
system and that the weight of this
building is a quarter of the weight of
concrete so it's the first thing we sit
down we say look we're building a
building that's a call to the weight of
concrete we don't need a tower crane we
can do the whole thing from the back of
a truck with a mobile crane we need
cause we need about a third of the
amount of foundations on this building
and also it's fast it's a very accurate
very easy material to work with and very
very fast so we did a comparative
program for the client showing them a
concrete frame building going up in
about 18 months and the equivalent
timber building going up in less than a
year and in fact when we from when we
started demolitions when the first
people moved in was 11 months so just in
terms of how we built this building
these panels here this is a diagram
showing the panel layout on one of the
floors here so these are the these are
the biggest panels we could get through
the channel tunnel which are about 36
feet long by about two and a half meter
wide so it's what
over eight feet by 36 feet and these are
our floor slabs here so you can see this
is a principle low path game from front
to back and then these are the walls
here so these are bedroom walls and you
can see this is the party wall in this
situation so this is one apartment two
and this is a big four bed apartment
here so you can see how they're
separated there so these are so we're
able to move these party walls across
the structure giving it very plan which
allows us to change the building as it
goes up so nine floors we've got five
different floor plans online floors so
in terms of fire the way that it works
in the UK is we have a system of
compartment ation which is where we we
separate we separate out the apartments
from each other by having a one hour
fire separation between each apartment
and then a two hour fire separation on
the lobby and the elevator shaft so the
idea being is that if there's a fire in
this apartment here then this apartments
got an hour to finish watching what
they're looking at on TV and then - and
then to get leave
so just in quick terms I'm doing it's
quite quickly so they'll give Michael
sometimes to talk about the work that
he's been doing but this is a section
through our building here so this is the
the floor slab which is a 6-inch timber
slab and then five inches for the walls
here and then we have an acoustic
insulation that goes and wraps up the
end there and we have a screed on top
and that's for an acoustic separation
but also gives us a thermal mass as well
so we were able to put underfloor
heating in this screed here and then we
have a void insulation and plaster ball
below here on the outside of the
building here we have a breather
membrane would you call that like a
Tyvek kind of stuff so yeah breathe it
so a breather membrane on the outside of
the building and then we won't run a
rail system down that and we'd push the
insulation on top of that and then we
have a simple rainscreen cladding system
on the outside which is made from a wood
pulp and Semin Tisha style so very
simple construction method hiya
that's it that's not schematic that's a
construction drawing painted green it's
that's really that it's it's a platform
construction sets so the wall panels sit
on the edge of the floor panels and
there's angles there there's a little
angle bracket that sits there and then
in localized positions we've got some
screws that sit underneath the wall
panel here just to strength just for
compression for creep on the edge of the
slab but that that's really it's um the
whole principle was to make sure that
the building was incredibly simple the
idea was always to to get the building
built so to make sure that the building
was in was very simple so that there
were no kind of um no complications for
the contractor no excuses for the
contractor to say oh it's just far too
difficult thing to do so he made it very
very simple you can see this is a
section here through the lift shaft so
we have a separate a separate panel here
for the lift shaft and these the
internal walls up against there so you
have just a 40 mil that's sort of an
inch and 3/4 separation between the two
so this should explain this is about an
idea here so this is the construction
processor this is our ground floor
concrete slab this is London here's my
office over there this is beautiful
isn't it so the process of construction
was that on a Tuesday morning a truck
arrived with four Austrian carpenters
and some panels on the back and then on
a Wednesday another truck arrived on a
Thursday another truck arrived and on a
Thursday night they went home to Austria
and we tucked up in bed so they built a
story in three days Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday and they built a story a week
so in 27 work days we built nine stories
and you can see no crane here and that's
the finished result my display once more
No
bracing for stability or for sheer no
because all the walls are working so all
the shear forces all the P Delta forces
if you like pass through the slabs pass
through the front elevation and down
that make sense so all that because all
because the connections run along the
length of each one of the wall each one
of the wall panels as we well the
because it's a platform construction you
laid so the first thing that happens you
lay the latest the floor slabs if you
like and then really the sequence of
construction across the building is you
know is you start in one corner you work
your way back you have a series of them
you have a series of angles of sort of a
temporary propping which you screw into
place to to hold the walls at 90 degrees
well they're dropped in by crane and
they're dropped in vertically so it
makes sense and you through you do put
in some temporary diagonals for a couple
panels to support them until you start
making the right angles that hold it
together yeah just just as you would
with light wood frame in that way when
you tilt the wallet so this is the UM so
this is some of the construction here
you can see this is the the first fix
here running through for the electrics
and for the and for the the gas lines
and you can see here the connections
that we're talking about so the whole
building is put together using 3-inch
galvanized brackets 18-inch centers with
four inch screws so that's three guys
with cordless screwdrivers and one guy
driving the crane the argument that we
had of the discussion that we had with
our developer client about the building
was that when we sat him down we
explained to him the environmental and
sustainable benefits of building this
building in timber he said the thing is
Andrew I don't give a monkey's for the
environment I'm not interested you can
have sell this to me in a completely
different way so we sold it to him on
the basis of speed and efficiency and
cost will cost equivalent to concrete
but we were six months quicker
so he said okay well that's fine we can
go with a temper system but I don't want
anybody living in this building to know
that this is a timber building because
I'm worried that they won't buy it if
they think this is some kind of like
sustainable exercise you know and they
are not going to touch the building at
all so we said okay fine we just want to
build the building so we covered the
interior of the building with gyproc
here which of the time is kind of you
know when you've got the soreness sort
of stage here and then you go to this
it's a little bit heartbreaking
especially being in this sort of
situation but actually I think that in
hindsight what's what what this is done
is to strengthen our argument in terms
of proving a viable alternative to
concrete steel because the viability of
this building has not been about the
aesthetic it's been about the structure
and the efficiency of the construction
process so that's actually worked very
well in terms of being able to talk
about timber as an alternative using
this building as an example and in
addition to that we leaked it to the
newspapers anyway and before the
building started on site there was a
two-page article in the local newspaper
and which has a circulation of about 15
million and they they'd said that this
building was going to be built on timber
and a week later the building was put on
sale off plan and the whole building all
29 apartments sold in an hour and 15
minutes and they sold to people who
cared about the environment they sold
people who actually were really excited
about the fact that the building was
built out of timber and and at this
moment are busily taking the gyprock off
the walls so you can see here this is a
this is during the construction process
and this is the end of the job so we
have here an inborn balcony no cold
bridging issues nothing like that we've
got a torch applied felt on the
balconies so I come up I came into the
site here onto the building site and
you've got some Polish bloke sitting on
the corner there with a blowtorch
in a timber building putting the felt on
which is a bit of a heart-stopping
moment so that we go finished product
okay so you know Andrews building has
been an inspiration for a whole lot of
people around the world including myself
we I had was a partner in a firm about
35 people until just a few weeks ago as
Mary said and I split off my firm with
this is move-in day just a week and a
half ago into our new space as I said
this is actually our new space in behind
the plot where's the pointer I use the
pointer where's your pointer that's
better these in behind here these are
timber columns holding up this 105 year
old building and you know it's a real
pleasure to work in a building like that
it's much like this building it just
feels natural and great so you know my
firm in my practice I built things all
over the world a lot of international
airports a lot of wood buildings as well
in the last decade and more and more as
I did that I became sort of vested in
the idea that there has to be this other
way around these discussions of climate
and so forth and around the work that
Andrews been doing what that triggered
is something you know sort of attitude I
guess in my practice and personally that
a lot of the conversation we've been
having about green environmental
buildings has been either the sort of
checklist approach to LEED buildings
which you know is a good thing or the
sort of tendency for us to try to create
additive buildings we'll put some photo
data annals on the outside we'll put a
green roof on them we'll sort of add to
the building with things in order to
somehow create a green argument around
the building and there's this sort of
sense that I had some time ago that
maybe we actually just need to hit reset
and and ask the question are we staring
at the trees are we looking at the
forests is there a big decision that we
could make that would make a more
profound change in the in the way
buildings work worldwide so finding the
forest through the trees actually became
the name of the system that I'm going to
describe now which is a new way that has
just been published to to build very
very large buildings about a year and a
bit ago we were we proposed and received
a grant funding to basically set out
with some engineers some cost
consultants some code consultants to
build what now is a 240 page document
that really
lays out the plans of how to build very
large buildings up to 30 storeys tall
and wood using this new system we
designed it very specifically around
Vancouver and we decided that our report
needed to demonstrate that this was a
rigorous from a technical point of view
but also rigorous enough to show that it
was cost-effective and tell the story
why consumers would want to buy it why
developers won't want to do it how
people would ultimately market these
ideas and also obviously the other sort
of critical parts of how they worked and
what their sustainable story really
would be so in Vancouver where I live
it's high Earth quake zone we want to
really challenge our system by building
in the highest earthquake zone in Canada
by proposing it in that environment and
also proposing it in a dense urban
environment and really work with
contractors to understand how we would
actually technically build something on
that scale so the system is actually
remarkably simple the first version of
this I built with my son when he was six
and we sat down on the ground together
and put it together sometimes the best
ideas are just that easy and I sort of
pulled I work with some outstanding
world-class
wood engineers at Vancouver I'm lucky I
come from a wood culture and there's
some outstanding wood engineers I've
worked with the engineers of this
building in New York and and my
engineers in Vancouver actually have
been helping the New York firm
understand wood a little more we we have
a great culture for wood and when I
pulled them aside I said guys you know
my son Macklin I've been making this and
I really think this is interesting and
this has some real potential to build
big and what do you guys think and they
sort of said yeah this actually works
and we started working on it more and
more over the last five years until we
reach this point where we realized that
it's not only possible it's actually
really practical to do this and it's
shaking things up a little bit in the
big conversation worldwide because this
just came out two weeks ago publicly
it's kind of an interesting moment for
me just personally for our firm because
what's happened is you know we spoke to
CNN a week ago and we're talking to
Bulgaria newspapers and some guy from
Iraq constant you know contacted me
about how to do this so it's become a
very quick and very instant conversation
because it seems so
Oh different the idea you know to get to
nine stories is astounding to talk about
30 stories obviously is a very new
paradigm shift for the world to get
their head around and and ultimately we
think it's very realistic much like what
Andrew just described the idea is
motivated by sustainable methods of
building these big urban buildings but
also it's about how we innovate for
faster lighter less expensive and better
performing for the global scales of
challenges and not those challenges
again climate change world housing we've
got to deal with them because as we talk
world housing especially in the
developing world the issues kind of
collide if we build the way we're
building today to solve that three
billion people that need a new
affordable home in the next 20 years we
are obviously going to significantly
impact climate footprint and we can't do
that there has to be a new way so the
the system as I say it's really simple
and in our case we use a little bit of
Steel it's effectively a 98% wood
building the elevator like Andrews
building the elevator cores the stair
cores are all would be using these mass
timber products but we use a little bit
of steel and the reason we do that is in
a higher earthquake zone we need
something that's ductile that gives a
little and gives it sort of has a little
more elasticity to it and so we use the
steel ironically as the weak joint in
the design so for anybody in engineering
this is a strong column weak beam design
and what's interesting in the way we
approach it is we had some of the best
seismic engineers in North America do
our peer review and what what's
interesting is the formula technical way
that an engineer now analyzes our
building is it uses the exact same
software you would in concrete so it's
actually very easy for a lot of
engineers to get their heads into how to
do this it's just using this very new
material the material is massed timber
materials that Andrew touched on
laminated strand lumber laminated veneer
lumber and CLT cross laminated timber
have been around for a long time
100 years ago and BC if you want to
build a fireproof wall you took two by
fours and nailed them together a two by
sixes and nailed them together and made
a massive solid wall so when I renovate
a building and in my community I'm often
a massive piece of wood and the only
reason it's there is because of fire is
completely hidden in the wall but what
we know is massive massive pieces of
wood actually resist fire and behave
really predictably in fire which is very
counterintuitive to the way a lot of
people feel about wood but the
difference is it's easy to light a fire
with a little piece of little sticks to
start it up it's very hard if you start
with a log and try to catch it on fire
it's very difficult to get it to work
that's why the torches on the balcony
weren't weren't lighting up necessarily
for for when they were putting the the
waterproofing on so just to kind of give
you an overview I'm not going to go into
a lot of the detail of our report but
what we were trying to do again is say
it's one thing to have a good
sustainable message but what we know
statistically is 95 percent of the
public will tell you that they will pay
more for something that is green but
only 5% actually do this system these
ideas don't sell because they're good
for the planet that's not what's going
to happen even though luckily Andrews
buildings sold out with people with that
attitude that's not going to propagate
the idea so instead we had to make this
cost effective when part of it was speed
and part of it was showing that it had
all the same flexibility as any concrete
building so this is a concrete building
and what we did in our study is we
actually looked at a 12-story concrete
building 20 storey concrete building a
30-story concrete building in every step
of the way because concrete's what we
build with in Vancouver not steel every
step of the way we would compare our
wood system to a concrete system no
matter what what the metrics were going
to be we would get a rigorous comparison
and what came really important in that
was that in order to get developers to
want to do these kinds of buildings they
want flexibility and we wanted to prove
that we could do this not just in
residential buildings but ultimately in
office buildings and in order to do that
you really want a plan a building plan
that's call it that's that's wall free
it's just open free plan so that means
in an office you can lay out your office
space however you want and you can build
if it was residential you can build your
residential unit wherever you want so in
our system we're using these large-scale
panels and we tilt them
and there are 64 feet long if they're
LVL or LSL so there's six storeys tall
when you've tipped them up and we're
building up to 12 stories we're building
with glulam columns just like these big
beams here slabs of these large mass
timber panels a central core and an
elevator core made entirely of the
timber panels and some steel Ledger's
that help us again with the flexibility
of the system what we found is up to 20
stories up to 12 we had this free
beautiful free open plan you could have
all glass exterior which a lot of
buildings are made that way that's not
the way hopefully we'll be building
buildings in the future because it's
obviously terrible from an energy
performance point of view but you know
this gives the developers flexibility
and what we found is if we move away
from the columns and put solid panels on
the exterior we can actually get up to
20 stories or we could put brace walls
inside a little bit more like Andrews
building with a few more load-bearing
walls on the inside and ultimately to
get to 30 stories we'd mix those two
things make a fairly solid exterior and
walls on the inside
since this diagram is made we've
actually been able to show that we can
do option two and three here all the way
to 30 stories which means that we can
make an office building 30 stories tall
and wood means we can make a flexible
plan for a developer to do a housing
project in 30 stories which is an
extraordinary sort of result that we
were truthfully a bit surprised by as we
push the engineering further and further
so I'm going to go quickly now in this
part but as I said what was important
about our system was that we tested
everything so the in this case we
actually met with construction companies
some of the biggest ones in Canada and
talked about how you would actually
erect them and for us what was funny
with that is that they didn't know who
to bring to the meetings then this isn't
something anybody does do we bring wood
carpenters no because these panels are
massive this isn't wood carpentry we
don't do we bring concrete guys no
because that doesn't make any sense
there really isn't a clear trade that
actually builds this it's probably
closest to steel in some respects
because it's kind of a kit of parts that
goes together but it's in many respects
kind of
this big unknown as nobody's been doing
it but they were excited about it and
that was what was great it's every
single group we talked to from
contractors to developers to Building
Code officials were really a intrigued
and B after they learned and read more
and understood what we were talking
about really all of the obstacles seem
to be slowly disappearing for us
everybody was coming on side because the
ideas seemed to be researched and
understood well enough and with the
contractors to our surprise we basically
are building up the central elevator
core bracing it and building in lifts of
six storeys at a time so you can see
these panels the elegance is basically
the simple way for everybody to think
about it is a two-by-four the way we
build small residential houses has now
become a giant piece of wood that's
eight feet wide and sixty-four feet long
and three and a half inches thick and at
times seven inches thick to allow us to
get these huge Heights so again without
going into any detail what I just want
to point out is throughout our study
what we were able to do is compare
concrete to steel I too would constantly
back and forth show how they worked
acoustically show how they worked in
fire show how they worked from a
building envelope point of view and our
sort of studies filled with millions of
these diagrams to really help articulate
and one of the things that almost became
a surprise to many people is that in
concrete a lot of the time we have
thicker slabs or thicker walls than we
would for the same building of the same
height and wood and the reason is quite
simple and are touched on it a wood
building is 1/4 to 1/6 the weight of a
concrete building so when you're
building in a high earthquake zone and
you build in concrete as you go higher
and higher the mass of the building
becomes very great and the forces that
you're trying to resist are very very
great because the building itself is so
heavy when you do it in wood you're
actually resisting less force and what
we found in a building that's twelve
stories tall in Vancouver you would
typically see the concrete walls around
the elevator shafts be a foot thick and
wood they were only nine and a half
inches thick so it was almost a huge
surprise to us that would actually
result in a more floor space and a you
know more simple system
so again we went through systems and how
they were integrated and we went through
all the different conditions of
balconies you don't need to kind of we
don't need to spend too much time and we
wanted to check the ball at boxes of the
standard challenges currently no
Building Code has imagined these systems
so certainly the code is a big one but
really the issues are kind of consistent
which shrinks and that's true but what
we when you build a very tall building
if it's as wood shrinks as it dries out
the problem is you can have real
technical problems with how that
building goes together in our system if
we built it on the right the platform
based system where you build up to a
certain height and then put a floor and
build up and put a floor in it would
actually result in adding up the floor
slabs and as you get very tall that
actually deals with a bit of shrinkage
although and result very little in his
building at 9 storeys once you're at 20
or 30 that can become a bigger issue so
what we've been working on is a system
where the floors are actually sit in
between and we don't absorb the
shrinkage and so it's really effective
in fact it shrinks about the same amount
as any concrete building would so that
solves some technical problems I'm just
going to keep going a little quicker now
so from a moisture point of view just
like in Murray Grove and Andrews project
we don't put the wood structure out
there for the weather to beat it up
there's always an envelope that protects
it and that's a really important thing
I'm slowly learning all the issues that
are the buzzwords for for the public
that right underneath the CNN article
all of their kind of concerns and
complaints and they're they're good
comments they're very standard comments
but there's also a lot that's just
misunderstood and there's no intention
to build these things and have them sit
out in the weather and rot and be
exposed to termites and so forth those
things are all taken care of acoustics
is the biggest issue probably the
hardest issue of all the things we dealt
with is just that in a big building
concrete resists the mass of the
concrete actually is very effective at
dealing with acoustic issues between
Suites in a building and getting these
buildings to work is very possible but
it also requires some pretty
sophisticated detailing and from a fire
point of view and Andrew touched on this
a little bit
we have two systems big tall buildings
in North America have to resist a two
hour fire and what that means is whether
the steel concrete or wood they just
they have to stand for two hours so that
the firefighters can get in them people
can get out of the building safely
firefighters can go in and fight the
fire and also the building doesn't
collapse during that time and damage
property or kill people down below it
that's just the way the codes work
naturally and to deal with that we had
to prove that we had an answer for to
our fire rating for a tall building and
the way we do that there were two
options one is that we just cover
everything in two layers of fire rated
drywall and that creates a two hour fire
rating with some very specific technical
details of how we do it
that's called encapsulation on the left
but the other that's more exciting and
for us in Vancouver the building code
authorities are really interested in is
something called charring where we
actually calculate the thickness of the
material of the wood on the outside that
will burn over two hours and there's
different calculations for it but it's
roughly six millimeters per minute and
if you calculate that or certain point
six millimeters per minute if you
calculate that over a two hour burn it's
going to be about two and a half inches
two hundred three quarters and in inches
of a burn that you will lose of wood and
that assumes your sprinkler system
didn't turn on pretty much catastrophic
conditions as long as the structure the
meat of the material left over after
that burn is strong enough to hold up
the building you've satisfied that two
hour fire rating and our codes in Canada
and I think here as well around heavy
timber buildings like this actually have
understood that for a hundred years and
so because of the nature of these big
panels that's how we actually can solve
fire at a large scale so that's the sort
of standard burn I mean in some parts of
the world we actually which is fun we
actually protect steel construction with
wood construction which just goes to
that counterintuitive reality that we
need to change people's perception of
wood and really ultimately this is where
we're at right now we're at that next
step with building it and worth in the
next few weeks I'm hoping we'll announce
in Vancouver that we're going to build a
20-story wood building which will be the
world's tallest for now and hopefully
somebody beats us real soon maybe it'll
be Andrew in London
I think that's it I think that's it for
now so we have in our presentation maybe
we'll jump to questions but what we also
have are some other example projects so
if you guys are interested we could also
just show you some of our work some of
the places we're using playing with
these materials
maybe we'll pull that up and then at the
same time you guys can ask questions
anybody got any